bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors vous avez
suivi notre édito à l'instant cette
question un peu plus sérieusement
comment expliquer la candidature de
kanye west
ok donc un peu de gravité mais c'est
difficile c'est bien sûr un sujet rigolo
mais de sérieuses on peut faire un
analyste ce campagne d'abord comment
promotion de ses produits ses chaussures
jesi ou à sa dixième nouvel album mais
ça n'explique pas le soutien pour son
candidat tort parce qu'il a ramassé des
milliers des signatures pour entrer dans
les points enregistrés comme candidats
dont moi personnellement je suis
convaincu que guy d'abord notre de la
société du spectacle par énormément de
quel phénomène donc en avait le sens de
programme reconnaît qu'à nier ouest de
calais 760 médiatisée par les imac est
dans une société de consommation où nous
sommes tous aliéné de l'un à l'autre à
travers l'écran elle a des rapports
humaine et la société devenue comme du
guide aborde une accumulation des
spectacles alors que kanye west
justement il n'a pas sans rapport est un
artiste il n'a pas l'appareil politique
en quoi cette candidature peut être
crédible comment est-ce qu'il peut
mettre en danger
donald trump ou liés ou à bien seul il
se rapproche en 2016
camier ouest a affiché qu'il était
républicain la pio parti démocrate votre
la plupart des noirs aux démocrates 20
8% des noirs en gothique hillary mécano
s 2016 a affiché son support pendant
longtemps donc d'abord il essayait
d'être différente année les noirs il n'a
pas un base du soutien noir mais ça veut
dire il y a les noirs république
kanu est un peu décrié retiens ma hand
religieuses comme gagnant un peu dire
car kany west représente une forme
religieux promenoir à la tendance
république c'est non c'est ça qui s'est
facilement transférables dans une plate
forme de promotion
le risque c'est que les votants qui
votent pour dans l'autre homme est pour
mais qui m'a pas soutenir cagnes est
ouest et qu'il va perdre une seule
marche des mots dans les étapes clés est
pour l'instant quand il n'y a pas
enregistré dans tous les états dans le
contexte actuel de dénonciation des
violences du racisme systémique dans la
dans la police aux états unis des
brutalités policières
cette candidature est ce qu elle fait
sens comment est ce qu'elle est perçue
par l'opinion américaine
ok donc il faut que j'aille un peu dans
leur complexité la 6me optique
donc il y a dix noix qui se présentent
dans cette sélection comme pour
t'initier vice-présidente de joe boyd
par exemple canal ailleurs donc il ya
les noirs sérieuse les les sénateurs il
ya des responsabilités dans le
gouvernement
et après on a gagné baisse donc sa mort
sassou manque de blake lively nadja et
c'est une digression dans le débat 2011
police des problèmes de racisme
institutionnel avec une caisse ou mange
en plus ça donne le sens comme les
moines sont assurés par il a de la
phobie les bipolaires et son soutien par
elon et la masca que faut-il en penser
oui ok c'est très intéressant
manager de compagne une corde un chien
dans la société spectacle l'autre les
célébrités partagent une sorte de
capitale culturelle et le soutien des
kills en masque c'est très important ça
semble donner la crédibilité la
légitimité mais vraiment si c'était une
campagne pour un boulot il faut avoir
des qualifications l'opinion lui
lorsqu'on ingénieurs de confort et un
mais dans la société du spectacle un
soutien d'une célébrité donne force aux
célébrités et les gens qui vont s'en
n'avons aucune idée de la politique
peuvent suivre
larry deux îles en hausse alors on parle
tout à l'heure de blacklight matters
matin cette question qui concerne la
pandémie qui touche fortement les états
unis ans était l'un des pays les plus
endeuillé au monde on l'a dit justement
cette candidature de kanye west ça peut
paraître complètement absurde dans ce
contexte là oui c'est une tragédie
principalement parce qu'un pourrait
avoir évité s'est mis des millions de
gens sont affectés par tous mais pour
l'instant les états unis restent dans le
déni pendant exceptionnalisme et sahil
puis il paie les factures aux fins de
cons
donc oui cagnes et ouais c'est encore
une sim thème de l'aliénation de la
société américaine de la fétichisme de
la marchandise
les gens sont vraiment éperdus et à la
plupart des gens aux états unis ne
n'arrive pas à regarder la télévision
pour leur actualité permet de lire un
journal
il pointe par facebook par twitter pour
le sony via elle a répondu toujours les
théories conspirationnistes et can you
est ça court très bien musicalement avec
mon parti de la publique américaine qui
sont perdus merci à vous donc la sieste
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines